il ya donc une commission parlementaire
sur le cannabis qui existe déjà depuis
cinq six mois commissions auxquelles
évidemment nous ne l'avons pas été
invités puisque le président de la
commission robert aide à afficher
clairement ses positions dans la presse
en soutenant ce qui est lobby pro
légalisation donc malheureusement on
voit bien que la commission s'oriente en
invitant que des gens qui sont pour et
chercherait j'ai regardé depuis le début
de la commission tout ce qu'il invitait
on peut dire il ya 90 % de gens pour 10%
de gens compte c'était plutôt les
gendarmes et policiers et quelques
joueurs de l'académie de médecine
donc suite à ça il a fait donc
effectivement une commission citoyenne
aussi qu'ils devaient rien donné on sait
très bien que les gens répondent très
peu sur internet et ça va être
effectivement une commission qui va être
là biaisé totalement moi c'est ce qui
m'inquiète un peu dans ce genre de
commission
j'ai participé à toutes les commissions
d'enquêté sénatoriale depuis
parlementaire depuis les années 95 je
m'aperçois que tu es là il suffit qu'ils
aient un président qui se fait avoir
indemnisation pour ceux biaisé il ya
quand même un tract succès parce qu'il
ya plus de 200000 réponse je crois déjà
d'enregistrer après on a un peu en demi
teinte chez un maul france parce que le
la façon dont ont été posées les
questions on va dire effectivement cadre
beaucoup la chose et je crois avoir eu
des retours de la part des organisations
de sa mission informations comme quoi
pour le moment ils avaient beaucoup
justement de réponses positives qui
allait dans le sens de l'égalisation et
ils étaient en demande de gens qui
étaient plutôt contre donc c'est pour ça
mathieu le bigot je vous invite à a
demandé aux gens qui sont plutôt contre
effectivement tout processus de
légalisation d'aller remplir et répondre
à ce questionnaire
après nous on se regarde effectivement
beaucoup de réponses beaucoup de
réponses apparemment positive ne donnant
plus sur comment ils vont exploiter ces
données
parce que si c'est un peu comme sur la
convention climat ou la passion d'antan
et posées ont été posés la question
clairement quand on a autant de réponses
ça me semble compliqué de pouvoir sortir
une tendance générale si vous regardez
depuis 40 ans à chaque période
électorale et on a et on va arriver en
période électorale on reparle de sujets
l'heure c'est typique de la france à
chaque fois vous allez avoir les
politiques qui sont pour les politiques
sont contre et finalement on va en
parler pendant tout pendant un an toute
la période électorale et après ça va se
calmer pour un certain temps et on en
reparlera aux prochaines élections et
ainsi de suite
ça fait des années que ça dure et ça
fait des années que j'entends toujours
le même discours en période électorale
on y revient dès qu on est sorti on
arrête donc on va été on va pas dessus
il ya quelques le problème c'est que
quand j'entends les p tits parler des
quantités de pays ont légalisé ce qui
est totalement faux que rappelait il ya
quelques états aux états unis et le
canada et l'uruguay on sait bien qu'ils
aient pas trop démocratique donc ils
l'ont fait mais malgré un référendum le
peuple avait dit non mais enfin bon on
va préciser réglé le débat a été
largement biaisée pendant des années et
maintenant on assiste à un renversement
parce qu'en fait il faut savoir que dans
la langue française on a le el34 21-4 du
code de l'ours et de quoi de la santé
publique qui interdit de faire une
présentation seront favorables une
substance stupéfiante ou de de valoriser
en fait son usage et cette loi a
maintenu la france et les français dans
une
on va dire une méconnaissance du
cannabis une méconnaissance c'est à dire
que on avait uniquement les mauvais
messages qu'il ya en l'occurrence la
parole de monsieur le bigot et son
association qui apparaissait dans les
médias sur la question du cannabis
là on peut voir que par exemple 60
millions consommateurs récemment s'est
intéressé aux produits du cbd qui sont
maintenant largement disponible dans les
boutiques cbd suite à l'arrêt can have
ap dont qui se trouvait que la france
était illégal au niveau européen ne
respectait pas les règles de comptes de
commerce international au niveau
européen et je pense que la parole va de
de ce fait de plus en plus se libérer
chaque fois qu'on légalise c'est pas les
adultes qui trinquent c'est les enfants
de 12 à 17 ans et ça c'est la vraie
question à se poser
pourtant j'ai tout ce que j'avais vu
pendant avant la légalisation que soi
que le rhône importe quoi il a assuré
qu'il était mineur mais ça c'est un peu
comme l'alcool en france on vous dit
maintenant la call center de mineure
mais trouvez moi un gamin qui est pas
capable d'acheter une bouteille d'alcool
en france
moi j'invite les gens de l'association
monsieur le legal à se prononcer pour la
légalisation parce que seule la
légalisation pourra protéger les jeunes
en l'occurrence la prohibition
actuellement est dans l'incapacité de
protéger la jeunesse et on le voit
récemment justement avec l'arrivée de
ces produits que ce soit des herbes ou
du haschich frelaté qui arrive ou voir
même des liquides frelatés qui arrivent
sur le marché noir et qui sont très
largement disponibles et là il ya un
vrai vrai vrai problème donc il va
falloir que la france change de
paradigme
voilà nous on est on est vraiment pour
la changement par un changement total